- [Voiceover] The
fundamental basis of life
comes down to this: the
struggle between good and evil,
the fight between light and darkness.
But in the DC universe,
things are not quite so clear.
Heroes are sometimes complicated
and villains are always complicated.
- Hi boys.
- [Voiceover] When it
comes to antiheroes,
no one tops the Suicide Squad.
The original Suicide Squad
first showed up in 1959.
Though it disappeared
until being resurrected
in its modern version in
1987, in the Legend series.
The squad is comprised of the world's most
dangerous criminals who are on something
of a work release program.
Assembled by government
operative Amanda Waller,
they are tasked with black-ops missions,
in exchange for a chance
to earn their freedom.
- Let's go save the world.
- That's a good idea, honey.
- [Voiceover] Through the
years, the squad has had
a revolving cast of characters,
with a few mainstays.
The crew assembled in David Ayer's take,
stemmed from the 2011 reboot of the comic.
There's Captain Boomerang, El Diablo,
Killer Croc, Enchantress,
Slipknot, and Katana.
With a few of them making
their live action debut.
And then there's this guy.
That's Deadshot, aka Floyd Lawton,
as he's known in the civilian world.
Obviously played here by Will Smith.
Deadshot showed up in
Gotham as early as 1950,
where he claimed to be a crime fighter,
before he emerges as Batman's enemy.
Here's the original, fancy Deadshot,
who looks like a cross between
the Penguin and the Joker.
His updated costume usually
includes an eye scope,
a mask and wrist mounted guns.
That's Harley Quinn,
one of the most popular
of all female comic characters.
- Seriously, the hell's
wrong with you people?
- We're bad guys, it's what we do.
- [Voiceover] The former Arkham
psychiatrist who went crazy
after falling in love with the Joker,
didn't actually make her debut in a comic,
but in Batman, the Animated Series.
Artist Paul Dini got the
inspiration for Quinn
while watching the soap
opera, Days of Our Lives,
where his friend Arleen Sorkin
was playing a clown in a dream sequence.
David Ayer maintained Quinn's iconography,
but updated it, giving Margot Robbie
a playful, but deviant look.
And what would Harley
Quinn be without the Joker?
Ayer's Joker, played by Jared Leto,
is tatted out and styled after drug lords
that Ayer saw on Instagram.
Controversial?
Maybe, but apparently
the tattoos tell part
of Joker's backstory.
- I can't wait to show you my toys.
- [Voiceover] Indeed,
Suicide Squad might be our
first chance to really explore
some of our favorite characters’ stories.
The time has come for
the bad guys to shine. `